en muchos titulares y mucha gente que
estaba protestando aquí a las afueras de
la corte suprema de justicia está
diciendo que esto abriría entonces la
puerta a que muchos estados no tengan en
cuenta las leyes federales la decisión
federal en el caso rubygate en 1973 de
aceptar el aborto antes de los 24 meses
de gestación mucha gente entonces acá
está diciendo que si esto ocurre cerca
del 50 por ciento sobre todos los
estados del sur empezarían entonces a
desconocer los mandatos federales y
darle prioridad a las leyes estatales es
decir a leyes que el caso de estados
conservadores estados sobre todo
republicanos pues bloquearían está
opcional de aborto que está vigente hace
casi 50 años en eeuu el washington post
y bis y asia en una encuesta reciente y
el 60% de los estadounidenses apoyaba
todavía el aborto sin embargo pues esta
polarización que vive el país se refleja
no solamente a nivel político sino en
este tipo decisiones judiciales y se ven
acá también en las afueras de el de la
corte suprema de justicia se está
escuchando en este momento allá adentro
estos argumentos y pues se estaremos muy
atentos a que siga después así es y esos
argumentos son los que dan comienzo a
este proceso cual es digamos todo el
camino a seguir en este caso para cuando
se espera que haya una decisión
se espera que la decisión esté a eso de
junio julio del próximo año y lo que
analistas están diciendo es que pues
esto puede presionar aún más a los
demócratas de cara a las elecciones
legislativas que serán tres meses
después 34 veces después en noviembre
del 2022 así que l esa decisión se
espera que se conozca a mediados del
próximo año el debate seguirá bastante
candente cómo se está viviendo en este
momento acá en la capital y lo que se
espera hoy entonces es que se emitan
unos argumentos por parte de los jueces
de los jueces supremos ustedes lo
mencionaban bien el sobre no hay seis
jueces supremos de tendencia
conservadora tres de tendencia liberal
estos estos seis esta mayoría
conservadora en la corte suprema se pudo
dar y por ende se pudo aceptar que se
considerarán nuevamente estos argumentos
y este caso de aborto precisamente por
los tres jueces conservadores que
durante la administración de donald
trump
el expresidente puso en la corte suprema
así que estaremos muy atentos porque se
vienen en próximamente estos argumentos
estas estas conclusiones por parte de
los jueces federales y a partir de ahí
pues se sabrá hacia dónde se inclina la
balanza que muchos analistas dicen se
inclinará a favor de los conservadores